[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est une très bonne après midi on
est le premier jour du hellfest on est
le vendredi 16 juin 2016 c'est la sat
aurélien santé c'est le lancement du
hellfest là pour l'instant ça se remplit
tranquillement mais bon ça commence à
arriver là on est à côté duquel il ya
des soirées privées dont les membres du
choeur donc ça va être cool et ça promet
effectivement ma d'avoir une
grosse grosse ambiance on n'est pas là
pour acheter
[Musique]
donc
m
[Musique]
je
au collet
d'accord
[Musique]
vous êtes magnifique merci lotissement
ben maintenant du temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là on est ce soir au hellfest
il y a eu il ya quelques instants il ya
même quelques mots aux instants
maintenant deep purple qui a joué
seulement comme the way c'était bien
pour un titre exceptionnel et efforts gt
line est toutefois sûr se protéger si
parce que ya quand même beaucoup ce
travail la journée
je savais que michael là on est en train
d'essayer de manger des sp le regard des
espèces de burgers fille qui vont nous
faire du bien dans ce club il faut se
nourrir ya le mois en notre nom du
festival
-votre nourrir c'est très important le
hellfest c'est vraiment que de la
musique plus de 300 groupes pendant
trois jours la ccal premier jour on va
vous faire suivre notre périple pendant
les trois jours au complet on vous en
dit pas plus pour l'instant on mange on
se nourrit pour vous montrer quelques
images
et franchement c'est génial et l'entêté
tatoué nord alors ça c'est ça c'est moi
c'est toi t'es content des petits
tatouages qui s'efface au bout de trois
jours
c'est dommage mais c'est un bon début
j'espère que ça vous plaît puis on se
revoit très vite trop beau et on
continue avec du bon son bisous bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coucou bonjour à tous aujourd'hui 2e
journée du reste on est toujours avec
avec mon très cher ami michael on part
effectivement au hellfest en cette
deuxième journée une deuxième journée
avec trust aerosmith sa bâtonnets
énormément groupe
on va essayer de se caler une petite
place vers le maine seage là il y avait
quelque chose comme call of
il y bientôt 16 heures mais bientôt ses
heures on est très en retard leur plaît
beaucoup de groupes mais on s'est
couchés extrêmement tard on a fini la
soirée au kkl c'était extra donc là on
va en profiter pour passer un bon moment
on va vous emmener avec nous ça y est
c'est parti
[Musique]
gagner en maturité il est trop mal fait
gagner en maturité je pense que tu es
vachement matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
station
richard
m
la q2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux bouteilles ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
troisième jour troisième jour du
hellfest est plus fort les doigts
excellent on a passé une super soirée
hier avec aerosmith
ce soir c'est keith et linkin park qui
joue il ya énormément groupe on va
essayer pour ce troisième jour de faire
un petit tour du hellfest d'abord un peu
tous les recoins les différents endroits
tout ce qui a fait franchir on
s'appelait steven n'a rien révélé
[Musique]
donc là on est à l'entrée du festival où
je vais retrouver un petit peu
bisous la négoce et de studio pour
métalleux
post apocalyptique 1 la détaxe anglais
des trucs de réparation américain c'est
vraiment la déco elle est complètement
dingue
[Musique]
là on peut acheter des billets pour le
ffs de l'année prochaine de toute façon
le fs tous les ans c'est complet sans
même que les gens reconnaissent nos
produits
[Musique]
si on peut faire des tatouages et des
piercings du vrai d'ailleurs y'a du
monde
rappelant de nouveau tatouage ce soir
au merchandising achat d'instruments
électroniques
là c'est le coin des bikers ont trouvé
chaussure à son pied ici aussi
[Musique]
voyage de bach
asselah consignes pour laisser ses
affaires c'est tout très grand c'est
super démesurée
la porte de l'enfer sans remettre
directement course
c'est le corner en manger
farcry aller partout
m
le chiot
mais comme très bon
[Musique]
la tournée dans un espace en plus
vieille ville en particulier celles de
bijoux
on peut y accéder uniquement avec ses
j'ai battu lahoud m brasse mais il ya
placé dans la cei en prison l'accès à
l'eau
et c'est un espace qui réserve est
vraiment prêt
et ben il ya des transats et nettoie
l'écran pics le site est exceptionnel
il ya des jo des plongeurs totalisé 4
heures du matin et il ya plein
et derrière il ya un chapiteau avec de
la musique
concert le soir etc
génial
[Musique]
donc là on est au market on peut acheter
mais les cornes de brume il ya des codes
pour moi
casquette et tee-shirt il ya des
pendentifs des baillis à tous
je sais pas sûr
m² mai
et l'or
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au revoir le hellfest c'était très sympa
et super festival trois jours de l fest
on est épuisés là on va rencontrer avec
les voitures secours voilà hall à
clisson clisson ville fucking rock
c'était juste génial merci le hellfest
mériaux n'avons qu'une voire merci à
vous d'avoir regardé à très bientôt nous
tiens
[Musique]